henri minutier bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin pour
décrypter les les futurs défis de la
folk peut-être cette première question
sur la forme le bundestag doit encore
élire son nouveau chancelier pas de
surprise ce sera bien olaf scholz
oui ce sera autre chose dont les
négociations se sont relativement bien
passée et surtout l'accord de coalition
a été largement approuvée par les
instances des trois des trois partis au
lieu des calculs critiques quelques
personnes qui ont voté contre mais une
très large majorité pour soutenir ce
nouveau programme donc grâce aussi à une
bonne majorité au parlement n'aurait pas
nié par les difficultés cela dit ce sera
intéressant de voir
le nombre éventuel de députés qui prend
soit s'abstenir soit voter contre cette
nouvelle coalition je parlais des
députés des propres artistes à dire sous
d'hippocrate les verts et les libéraux
qui permettra la nouvelle coalition
alors
premier premières priorités affichées
par olaf chose elle et elle est
écologique quand il lance un grand
projet de modernisation industrielle
pour freiner le changement climatique
est ce que c'est une continuité de la
merkel on peut parler d'une rupture
nancy ne s'est certainement une
continuité mais je pense que l'accent
sera mis beaucoup plus fortement
maintenant que c'était le cas autrefois
donc c'est très bien de prendre cet
engagement
le seul problème c'est se voir comment
elle va être financé et c'est là où je
vois un possibilité soumis de conflits
je dirais presque majeur au sein de sa
coalition on a d'un côté les verts qui
poussent à une modernisation et un
engagement très fort en matière de
protection de l'environnement de l'ue
contre le climat et de l'autre côté le
parti libéral avec monsieur geithner qui
va être le ministre des finances et qui
lui fait très attention à la rigueur
budgétaire et qui risque de ne pas
accepter un financement très important
engagement financier trop important en
faveur de cette lutte contre le climat
c'est là si oui je crois un des points
lundi des sources de conflits importante
au sein de cette nouvelle coalition
alors une nouvelle fonction pour la
flotte en pleine pandémie l'allemagne
qui a dépassé fin novembre le cap des
cent mille morts des 6 millions de cas
liés aux coronavirus ça semble baisser
cependant ces derniers jours il entend
mener une politique sanitaire sous le
signe de la fermeté
oui il entendu tout à fait mais là aussi
il ya une double difficulté si vous
voulez c'est que la santé très largement
une compétence des régions et non pas du
bund c'est-à-dire de l'état fédéral donc
il va essayer de gagner un peu plus de
donner plus de compétences à l'état
fédéral dans cette matière là mais ça va
être difficile étant donné
l'étendue et la diversité des politiques
des 16 10 16 länder alors une mesure
phare qui voudrait introduire c'est la
vaccination la vaccination obligatoire
cette question a déjà été fortement
controversé sous le gouvernement merkel
et on peut s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait
aussi une très forte opposition dans
l'opinion publique mais qui estime que
c'est là la remise en cause d'un droit
fondamental qu'il inscrit dans la
constitution
il est vraisemblable que même si le
parlement ne parvient à voter une loi
allant dans le sens de la bac citations
qu'il y aura un appel devant le tribunal
constitutionnel et ce sera lui qui devra
décider si oui ou non la vaccination
obligatoire que celles concernant le
premier symbole fort montré par olaf
scholz sera sa toute première visite
officielle elle est réservée à la france
ce sera vendredi
quelle est sa vision du couple franco
allemand
on sait pas grand chose on sait pas d'un
jeu moi même j'ai eu l'occasion de
discuter avec lui il ya deux ans à
hambourg tous cette question j'ai trouvé
qu'il était assez
c'est rude en a c'est amy bon cela dit
connais très bien les enjeux de la
coopération franco allemand a tant donné
qu'il a été il a été ministre des
finances donc il a une coopération assez
étroites et avec la france notamment
donc avec monsieur mais monsieur le
maire il a été reçu par le président de
la république monsieur m'accroche juste
avant les élections ainsi que monsieur
le situationnisme n'a donc si vous
voulez la relation avec la france pour
lui quelque chose de tout à fait
habituelle je pense qu'il a il aura pour
un souci de développer cette développer
cette coopération mais là aussi il y
aura certainement des limites notamment
sur les questions laisse la question
budgétaire
il aura fait un ministre c'est à
l'unisson des finances qui met l'accent
sur la nôtre doc simule jetair non
seulement au niveau national mais aussi
au niveau européen au franc serait
plutôt décidé à ce que lille y ait un
nouveau plan de relance au niveau
européen et là du côté allemand on
freine très nettement sur 7 sur cette
question donc ce ne sera pas facile de
même que sur les questions de sécurité
les problèmes si vous voulez militaire
il est évident qu'il y aura il faudra
beaucoup de travail pour rapprocher les
points de vue et sur la scène
internationale pour conclure quels sont
les défis qui attendent olaf schulze
berry tellement les premiers rayons d'un
défi personnel aylett de la nouveauté ce
gouvernement c'est pour la première fois
le ministre des affaires étrangères sera
une femme pour la première fois en
allemagne et une femme relativement
jeune et qui n'aa je dirais pas beaucoup
d'expérience en matière de politique
étrangère si quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
été ministre et qui sait pas jusqu'à
maintenant particulièrement illustré par
ses prises de position sur des questions
sur la question donc de politique
étrangère qui semble d'après ses
premières déclaration vouloir mettre
l'accent des surfaces comme elle
appartient au parti des verts et le
mettre l'accent sur des questions
d'environnement
mais est ce que c'est que questionner
sur tout à fait compatible avec une
politique étrangère assez vaste je crois
qu'il y aura aussi pas mal de problèmes
dans les relations avec des pays de
l'est et notamment avec la avec la
russie car madame albert boc a fait des
déclarations assez dure dix ans 800 a
aussi des droits de l'homme les
questions de l'édition de réfugiés et
c'est donc là il très grande inconnue le
comment va-t-elle le comment va-t-elle
réussir s'il venait à prendre en main ce
ministère des affaires étrangères et
quels seront ses que seront ses
principales lignes d'action c'est le
franco-allemand et l'europe sont
soulignés mais il ya aussi toutes les
questions internationales rapports avec
la russie rapport avec l'inde avec la
chine rapport avec avec le temps on sait
que les verts sont plutôt deux tendances
l'une des tendances pacifistes sont
hostiles à l'arme nucléaire ou question
nucléaire donc si vous voulez
la mise en place la politique c'est
l'allemand ne sera pas très facile au
cours des prochaines années d'autant
comme je suis ça je tiens à le souligner
on aura affaire à une mini scène
étrangère qui n'a pas beaucoup
d'expérience à la matière merci beaucoup
henry ménudier pour votre éclairage ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes
professeur honoraire à la sorbonne
spécialiste de l'allemagne